the british government has come under
criticism after newspaper reports that
it's considering plans to house asylum
seekers offshore
on remote islands since august more than
a thousand migrants have made
illegal crossings from the french port
of calais after promising to secure the
borders
london is under growing pressure to stop
the crossings
pictures that made headlines in the uk
this summer
people in rubber dinghies making their
way across the english channel
seeking asylum now the royal navy and
the air force are being deployed
to stop them nazir
a sudanese citizen trying to get to
england isn't phased
the government doesn't want new people
to like fool the country
but the country is a big it can't take
anyone
so we will find a place there
nazir is on the french side at the port
of calais
trying to figure out when he can cross
the city's been an asylum transit hub
for years
but infrastructure for the almost 1500
refugees
is practically non-existent a tense city
on the edge of a road little electricity
or access to running water
regular police checks
here there are no reception centers
[Music]
in lay-bys and roadside green areas
refugees meet
to discuss their only hope of getting
away by rubber dinghy
the sport like people use people in
europe use as a tour
to enjoy ourselves in naxxy
but we use it to which is a uk
so it's like some people use the
machines that
push apart around and some people they
have motor
so from here to uk about 34 kilometers
it takes about three hour
three hour and a half if people use the
hand it takes about
10 hour to 11 hour most boats set off
just after dawn
the french police have to keep an eye on
45 kilometers of coastline
this summer they've had reinforcements
the british are paying for an extra 45
officers a day
some of them on horseback but still
they're only able to prevent a fraction
of the risky departures
rescue crews are called out almost every
day the english channel is one of the
busiest shipping lanes in the world
the english channel is a motorway and
driving on a motorway with a scooter is
dangerous and that's what it's like here
but that hasn't stopped hundreds of
people trying to do it
every day after all nazir says
they have nothing to lose
i would do it refugees and migrants have
always faced stark odds
the latest measures have made those odds
even starker
you